- This is gonna' get weird.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I love Bob Ross.
He's like "Do it this way if you like to.
"If it looks different
from mine, it's okay."
- There's something so hypnotizing
about the way he speaks,
and it's just so soothing.
- I know he's a painter, but I totally
had no idea that he was dead.
I thought he had a new Netflix show, so.
- Let's do this.
- Let's go right in here,
and just put in a happy little glow.
- So I'm painting like,
it looks like a sunset.
I think I did mine
darker than his, though.
- Kay, hold on, Bob,
give me a second here.
- So he does move quickly.
- Eh, fine, sure, yep.
- Wants it to blend now, and
I don't feel good about this.
- This is lookin' good!
I legitimately feel like
I'm doing a good job.
- Bob, Shit, Oh God.
- (muttering) Dammit, what, suck it.
- I'm using the wrong brush, shit!
- All we're doing is applying some very,
very basic little shapes.
Think about the shape of a tree.
- I'll think about the shape of a tree.
Oh God, oh God. (laughs)
- Well that one kinda' looks like a tree.
I feel good about that.
- Blending, we're
blending, we're blending.
- I think we're using the same brush,
but for whatever reason,
what I'm doing is not what he's doing.
- Trees look a little bit like penises,
but you know what, what are you gonna' do?
(growls)
- The left side looks
better than the right side.
This looks like trees,
this still looks crazy.
- And here, maybe, lives
a happy little bush.
This is what keeps the little
rabbit warm in the winter.
- It keeps a rabbit warm in the winter.
Ugh, heartfelt, this scene
is not just a painting.
There's life in it!
- I think this is salvageable if
I just stick to the lower half.
- Bob's voice is what I
imagine like, if Mufasa,
Morgan Freeman, and God decided
to teach a painting class.
(tapping loudly)
- I think these are supposed to be bushes.
I can't be sure anymore.
(sighs loudly)
- If Bob and like the Reading Rainbow guy,
did they ever team up?
Because them together, like if Bob
and the Reading Rainbow guy,
I can't, I think his
name's LaVerne, a duo.
It's not LaVerne?
- Okay, so now we're basically making
the whole ground with
this nice blue, which,
I'm finally getting the knack
of not having too much paint.
- I guess Guy Fieri is
kinda' the Bob Ross of food,
just way less likable.
Was that kinda' mean to say, sorry.
Shit, what, what, what?
- My confidence is back down.
I felt great, and now I'm like, "Oh, Crap.
"Mine doesn't look like that."
- Maybe today we'll have a big old cabin.
- Cabins, I was always
amazed by his cabins,
because like, "What?"
He's like, "Three strokes, and
"there you have it, a beautiful cabin."
- Touching and pushing at the same time.
- Can we paint it something
cooler, like a bear?
- Oh God, I don't know how to do this.
- I can't even imagine like,
if you're watching this IRL,
commercial television, you can't pause.
Who did this?
- Oh, yes.
- I just like the sound
of this. (scraping)
- The knife is always my favorite part,
because he works some fuckin'
magic with this thing.
- Okay, so it's like a Christmas
getaway for me and Bob.
The economy's bad, so
no gifts this year, Bob.
- I'm just not even
gonna' try the windows,
'cuz it's clearly gonna' be a hot mess.
- Um, I'm not feeling great,
this feels a little bit crazy.
He's crazy, everyone's crazy,
I'm crazy for thinking I could do this.
- I think we'll call that
one finished, in fact.
- Wait, we're done?
What? (laughs)
- Thank you Bob, I'll see you next time.
Um, okay. (laughs)
- Yeah, I think I'm done.
(orchestral music)
- I had to pause multiple times,
and mine looks like complete
garbage after like an hour.
My trees are definitely gonna' need
some therapy before they're happy trees.
- I am most proud of my
tree here on the right.
It looks like it's ready for Christmas.
He has a special place in my heart
that only Bob Ross can have.
I feel like I was about to
cry and I don't know why.
- This looks like a
thing, like a human person
would be like, "Hmm, sure."
I made this, and how
many people can say that?
Thanks, Bob.
- I'll see you next time.
(orchestral music)
(squeaking)